[Applause]
[Music]
mexico has suffered so much political
corruption and for so long that it has
caused a leader like andres manuel lopez
obrador visual politics anti-award
winner to become a very popular
politician in spite of all the failures
he's racked up in his few years at the
head of the government amlo is not the
classic populist who shouts insults but
he does have what is perhaps the most
important quality of any good politician
he knows how to offer citizens exactly
what they most want at any given moment
so previous presidents burned through
money well amlo proved himself different
for example here are a few measures he
travels economy class he turned the
presidential residence of los pinos into
a sort of cultural center and dispensed
with the presidential 787 aircraft which
by the way nobody seems to know what to
do with the point is that actions of
this kind arose popular sympathy and
don't get me wrong many of these things
may be fine particularly if we take into
account the luxurious lifestyle that
typically characterizes mexican
presidents and top politicians but the
problem is when these things are used to
justify all government action and it is
even worse when the popular support
harvested is used to cover up the fact
that the economy is not going well or
that the management of the pandemic has
been terrible the fact is that despite
the very high crime rate the ailing
economy and the pandemic lopez obrador
maintains a very high approval rating
among mexican voters
for those of you who don't know lopez
obrador is popularly known as amlo for
short of course this is not an
abbreviation that amlo uses himself
practically every day and for the
greater glory of the president that is
for herself he holds press conferences
that last more than two hours and that
begs the question does the president of
a country like mexico have nothing
better to do apparently not check this
out
is
[Music]
that
a handful of words in 19 seconds with
such long press conferences sometimes
you don't even know what to say so why
are we on visualpolitik even talking
about amlo well it's best not to get
your guard down in front of this affable
grandfather who when he wants to is also
nice and even endearing and i say don't
let your guard down because amlo's
presidency is carrying out what is known
as the fourth transformation of mexico a
political plan that consists of putting
an end to repealing overturning the
reforms of his predecessors in order to
implement his own initiatives in all
kinds of areas
the problem is the amlo's initiatives
have a lot to do with typical latin
american policies that time and time
again have proven to be unsuccessful and
usually end up scaring away productive
investment this is precisely what is
happening with the energy sector in two
very clear areas on the one hand there
is the electricity reform on the other
the direction taken by the state-owned
oil company hemix under his presidency
and do you know what it's amlo's energy
reform that we want to take a look at in
this video today what is happening in
mexico's oil sector what does amlo's
electricity reform consist of and more
importantly how can all these measures
affect mexico's economy today on
visualpolitik we're going to answer all
these questions but first let's look at
some history
the state monopoly
[Music]
just a century ago mexico was the second
largest oil producer in the world behind
only the united states at that time the
sector was dominated by foreign
companies the once dominant company
mexicana el aquila had been acquired by
the anglo-dutch royal dutch shell there
were also plenty of u.s companies
operating south of the border however
they soon lost interest in the mexican
deposits the british began to exploit
oil in the middle east and the americans
in venezuela you see the problem for
these companies with the local labor
movement was one of the pillars on which
president lazlo cardenas relied when
they arrived the oil companies had no
idea the mess they were getting into
in 1938 a labour conflict spilled over
into the political arena when the oil
companies tried to avoid complying with
a supreme court ruling in favor of the
worker's demands and trying to dodge
complying with the ruling the foreign
companies saw how labour issue became a
dispute over the nation's sovereignty so
president cardenas intervened directly
in the matter by decreeing the
nationalization of the oil industry
three months later cardenas decreed the
creation of petroleo mexicanus pemex the
state-owned company that received the
monopoly to exploit and manage the
country's oil fields
[Music]
the move seemed to work out well for
mexico why well let's just say that in
the 1940s the united states and the
united kingdom had other much more
important concerns than passing the bill
to mexico in addition world war ii and
post-war economic growth greatly
increased the demand for crude oil
making nationalization the perfect
business and take note because the oil
sector was not the only energy sector
that the president intervened in before
that he had already meddled with the
electricity sector
[Music]
in 1937 cardenas founded cfe the federal
electricity commission its purpose was
to operate in a non-profit sector based
exclusively on technical principles the
objective was to obtain the highest
possible yield at the lowest possible
cost this meant the private companies
were only interested in the most
profitable areas the main cities and
industrialized areas and so the federal
electricity commission was left with a
rural and remote areas
[Music]
obviously this system didn't work it
ruined the state-owned company and on
top of that more than half of mexicans
were still without electricity so what
solution do you think the mexican
government adopted let's see perhaps uh
privatizing the market or favoring
competition and
encouraging investment maybe no nothing
of the kind in 1960 president aldolfo
lopez mateos completed the
nationalization of the electricity
sector and you know what at first it
didn't seem to work out too badly mexico
had more than enough resources to deal
with the bad decisions and maintain huge
subsidies for electricity consumption
remember that the countries with oil
were the noble reach on the
international scene and that's been even
more the case since the 1970s
[Music]
the oil crises of 1973 and 1979 boosted
the price of crude oil multiplying
pemex's income from all of its exports
in addition in 1979 the cantor rail
complex one of the largest oil fields in
the world began operating the problem
was the success of mexican governments
had complete control over the oil
company and did not run it with a
business mentality on the contrary they
squeezed it with multiple taxes and
royalties to feed the state coffers this
left pemex with far fewer resources to
invest and expand
[Music]
the canter rail complex reached peak
production in 2004. that year was also
the highest production year in the
history of pemex 3.4 million barrels of
crude oil per day since then it has
plummeted year after year to around half
that number now in 2020. of course faced
with cantarella's decline the remedy was
almost worse than the disease pemex
invested 70 billion dollars between 2010
and 2012. and the exploration and
production of crude oil the problem is
that most of it was invested in areas
for which pemex was technically ill
prepared such as deep water drilling and
fracking disaster was guaranteed to make
matters worse the investments were made
primarily with debt because the mexican
government was unwilling to stop
receiving its paychecks so pemex's
crisis was exacerbated by these bad
investment decisions
[Music]
and if we add all this to the corruption
that dominated the company for decades
and decision-making that was more
motivated by politics than business that
for example caused the oil company to
have a much larger workforce than
necessary what we are left with is an
oil company that is up to its neck in
debt coupled with dwindling production
mexico's jewel was about to fall to
avoid this happening it was clear that
many things had to change and that task
was given to none other than one of the
government's most tainted by corruption
the worst rated in mexico's history that
of enrique pena migneto so of course no
matter what was done any measure would
be tainted even if the reform was going
in the right direction
the fact is that the 2013 energy reform
ended pemex's state monopoly over the
oil sector opening up to private
investment foreign companies were
allowed to bid in transparent auctions
broadcast online to take over the
exploration and production of oil fields
it also opened the way to reducing the
number of pemex workers which has gone
from 151 000 employees in 2013 to the
current of 120 000. nine oil auctions
were completed until they were halted in
july 2018 when amlo won the election
the balance to date is that 111 fields
were awarded in those auctions and 34
have already started their exploration
so far 18 billion dollars have been
invested the mexican state's oil income
established in the contract has
approximately 74 one of the highest
percentages in the world so what does
all this mean
basically the reform attracted
multi-million dollar investments from
foreign companies private companies that
risk their money and exploration and
extracting oil but then pay the mexican
state most of the income derived from
its production all this without the
mexican government investing a single
peso sounds like a good deal doesn't it
well as always there is someone who
disagrees and this is what amlo used to
say when he was leader of the opposition
[Music]
a mexico amlo raised a fierce opposition
against pena nieto's energy reform as a
good populist he went so far as to
promise that he would hold a referendum
so that the people could express
themselves through the reform but as
visualpolitik fans know by now politics
is one thing and governing is another in
december 2018 amlo was inaugurated as
president of mexico in other words
enough time had passed to begin to see
what's happening in regards to the
president's energy policy check this out
[Music]
give me more guests
[Applause]
[Music]
lopez obrador has held popular
consultations of all kinds to see if he
should build a railroad lane or an
airport but the promised consultation on
what to do with energy reform well no
not that one that one was forgotten of
course this has not prevented pemex from
continuing to be a headache for the
mexican government although amlo talks
about the state-owned oil company as if
it were the jewel in the crown the
reality is very different years go by
and losses accumulate for pemex
something difficult to understand when
extracting a barrel of crude oil costs
an average of seven dollars and can be
sold for 10 times more of course the
mexican state then strangles pemex with
taxes keep in mind that one-third of the
aztec country's public spending is
sustained by the resources extracted
from the state-owned oil company and if
we add to this the fact that the rest of
pemex's business is a real ruin then
news like this comes as no surprise
pernx among the 10 most indebted
companies on the planet we're talking
about a debt of more than 100
billion dollars a debt that sets new
historical records every year
[Music]
so lopez obrador has set to work to
revive the state-owned oil company the
first thing amlo has done is to approve
a new hydrocarbons law with the purpose
of favoring pemex in the service station
market then regarding the opening up to
foreign investment in mexican oil fields
amlo bet on renewing the contracts
already awarded to check whether or not
there was corruption in addition as we
have already seen oil auctions were
suspended from the very moment he won
the elections recently the most
dangerous thing for mexico is that its
government has wanted to go a step
further and has acted directly against
the interest of a consortium that has
already invested 325 million dollars in
mexico and is headed by the u.s oil
company talos energy the result of these
measures is that a very negative message
has been sent to investors and all for
what well to benefit the same old people
mexico's biggest private oil find will
be operated by state-owned pemex as it
stands the result is that in spite of
everything when amlo came to power the
mexican oil company was producing 1.8
million barrels today the figure is
around 1.6 million and everything points
to the fact that things are not going to
get much better
[Music]
then if there is one thing that is truly
surprising about the mexican economy is
that a country that has so many oil
deposits is forced to import fuels
because its refineries date back to the
19th century this is an anomaly that
amlo has set out to resolve the problem
is that the bill is accumulating way too
many zeros so far more than six billion
dollars have been invested in
modernizing the state oil companies
refineries and in buying shell out of
half a refinery in texas whose ownership
was shared with pemex so why end a
partnership with shell that has worked
so well when pemex manages its own
assets so badly but wait a minute
because that is practically nothing
compared to the nearly nine billion amlo
is spending on one of his star projects
building a refinery in his own state of
tabasco amlo wants nothing to come
between pemex and mexico's
self-sufficiency and fuel production and
when i say nothing i assure you i mean
absolutely nothing
pemex is building refinery in green area
it promised to protect the point is that
the mexican government is now pulling
out all the stops to ensure that the
country produces all the fuel it
consumes by 2023. the problem is that as
we have seen it does so following a
recipe very similar to the one mexico
has been following for years oil
nationalism and a lot of interventionism
without taking business criteria too
much into account well enough about oil
what about the other arm of the energy
reform what about the electricity sector
check this out
the constitutional reform
the nationalization of 1960 turned the
electrical sector into a state monopoly
in the hands of the federal electricity
commission this remained the case until
the 1990s when a timid opening up to the
private sector took place the so-called
self-supply model was implemented a
mechanism that allowed companies to
bypass the commission and purchase
electricity from generation plants of
private power companies in a formula
similar to ppas that is power purchase
agreements openness to the private
sector gained momentum with pena nieto's
energy reform which boosted an
investment in electricity generation a
wholesale electricity market was
established that gave priority to the
cheapest and most renewable energy
suppliers sounds pretty good right not
to amlo as pena nieto relegated the cfe
to the background amlo dedicated a good
part of his efforts during 2021 to
implementing an electricity reform that
would strengthen the mission that is the
government
in a way amlo's electricity reform
caused great controversy by changing the
order in which power plants dispatch
energy in the first place the cfe's
hydroelectric fuel oil and coal plants
would come into operation in second
place the gas combined cycle plants that
generate their energy for the commission
after these plants private wind and
solar energy packs would follow and
finally the combined gas cycles of
private companies
let's see who would think of giving
priority to thermal power over
renewables wind and solar need to be put
to work when there is sun and wind when
there is none you put the thermals to
work otherwise it doesn't make much
sense that is basically electrical
systems 101 you're all welcome the fact
is that lopez obrador approved this
reform months ago but a court paralyzed
it in a country with legal certainty
this would have been the end of
electricity reform but not in amlo's
mexico
mexico president threatens
constitutional change if power bill
struck down and as we say right here no
sooner said than done
[Music]
the problem for the mexican president is
that he does not technically have a
sufficient majority to approve it and
now there is no longer talk of
dispatching orders but of quotas the aim
is to guarantee that the cfe's power
plants produce 54 of mexico's
electricity and at this point you may be
wondering why all this effort well
basically because in 2020 a new
international regulation came into force
that limits the sulfur and the fuels
used by shipping companies until then
this is one of the main markets for the
fuel oil produced by pemex refineries
they are so obsolete that they have
proved incapable of reducing their
sulfur levels so this is ammo's
objective to use the cfe thermal plant
to burn fuel oil that nobody wants to
buy from pemex all of this despite the
fact that it pollutes much more and its
generation costs are 25 higher than
those of new renewable plants in other
words amlo does not care whether mexico
produces more expensive or dirtier
energy the only thing he cares about is
to refloat mexican state-owned companies
at any price and if in the end that
means increasing subsidies so that
mexican's electricity bills do not go up
well so be it let's just pull out the
checkbook and even with that it's not
the worst thing look at this
with amlo's reform mexico will not only
have more expensive and dirtier energy
but also looking at the forecasts 40
billion dollars worth of investments in
wind and solar energy are in jeopardy
all of this is worrisome from mexico's
future because as to the downturn in
investment since amla won the election
this may end up becoming a lost
opportunity now that multinationals are
looking to diversify their supply chains
outside china but investors do not trust
the mexican president the data speaks
for itself
[Music]
but at this point the question is over
to you do you think it is right to
prioritize the interests of state-owned
companies over the installation of
renewables and what do you think of the
reforms undertaken by amlo you can leave
me your answer in the comments below and
as always if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik take it easy and i'll see
you next time
[Music]